raise your hand if you haven't brushed
your hair in over 24 hours
no I may be screaming no no you know
your life is different now currently
it's Monday morning nope it's Monday
afternoon it's almost 1:00 p.m. a lot of
people like to see the glass half-full
I like to see the time is half earlier
than it actually is for the weekend I
have endeavoured in to fully cleaning
out my house I rented a dumpster I have
been throwing so much away and because
I'm still in the middle of this chaos
there's everywhere and it makes me feel
a little out of control the one thing I
can control are my own physical
aesthetics so I thought what an
appropriate time to get a little bit
more in control and do a get ready with
me video this looks great but it can be
better
I've never been a morning person because
I do YouTube and digital stuff and I
work from home my lifestyle it's like
kind of not on a routine you one
actually grounding thing and this is
gonna sound like a cheesy branded like
insert at Rita's but also it's very
genuine
I know groan roll your eyes whatever I
don't give up I like this company a lot
and take this with whatever grains of
salt you want conscious of your salt
intake sodium you know looking out for
you
LM Ted's Excellent Adventure just got a
brand-new movie airborne think I look
like I should have competed in that Arab
is a company that I enjoy very much in
the subscription service that delivers
vitamins and supplements that are
personalized for you directly to you and
that is the most amazing thing that I
can imagine because one I like to be
healthy too
I don't like to go into vitamin store
and try to talk it's someone that
clearly has a much healthier lifestyle
basically go on the website you take a
quiz ask you about your diet lifestyle
your health goals and you can be so
blatantly honest because you're not
looking into the eyes of someone that
knows you're lying and they create a
personalized scientifically backed like
a vitamin regimen for you also you can
change your subscription at any time
depending on like what you need at the
moment you can lean more into like hair
health bone health energy etc also they
have vegan and vegetarian supplements so
something for everyone if you are at all
interested in carob
go to take care of calm and use the
offer code great age to get 25 percent
off your first order Thank You Kara for
sponsoring this video
Oh gross fun cute my aesthetic dog from
neverending story on acid so I have some
stuff to do today and I figure my house
is a mess and mayor's will make my
person slightly less of a mess I have
all the [ __ ] that I normally smash into
my face and in my hair here and I'm
gonna take you through a very genuine
get ready with me let's start with our
face you texture fun I hate washing my
face know that that's insane to say I
hate washing my face at a sink because I
splash water everywhere I'm basically
like a log flume makes me mad so dad a
lot of times this is what I do I know
everyone out there's gonna cringe but
this is a very honest get ready with a
big fan of wipes so what I usually do is
I take a makeup wipe and I end up taking
off the makeup that I probably slept in
the night before fully scrub it down
sometimes I wake up with that leg I can
my situation because I didn't take off
my mascara fun I look like I have
allergies and jaundice at the same time
I know makeup wipes are not supposed to
be the only thing that you should do is
because it feels still like there's like
a little bit of a film on my face so I
know any aesthetician any dermatologist
anyone that has a general better like
skincare routine is gonna hate this
currently I use these to eautiful gentle
skin cleansing cloths because these to
me don't feel like makeup remover and
this feels like I'm actually cleansing
my face like like a toner in a way so go
nuts in the comments about how terrible
this is so essentially I've just washed
my face I think I maybe do my skincare
routine like I'm camping when I am in an
actual place with electricity and
plumbing the next thing I do is I add a
bunch of these sent to me the Mario
Badescu skincare I've talked about this
in videos before the cucumber and green
tea I spray on during the day because
that seems like pick me up here we go
you got in my mouth I think I like this
but I am so in swayed by advertising
this could be
actually just two tonic water with green
food coloring in it and I'd be like
smash it in it i T
it's called by by under eye eye cream
deep puffer I put this under my eyelash
that in a little bit it's gonna make a
huge difference then I try to put a
moisturizer down I got this it IT secret
soft that's how you do it I feel great I
feel great all the the the silent
killers are all on the face and in the
crevices that need to be there for the
most part so now let's do our makeup and
then we'll do our hair and clearly
everything that I will be doing on and
around my face will make you mad at some
point so just take it just take it bare
minerals started sponsoring my podcast
and I got really fascinated with them so
I bought their complexion rescue tinted
hydrating gel cream I thought was like a
tinted moisturizer and I think it still
kind of is it has a great coverage that
you can use it by itself but I get crazy
about wanting like full coverage face
makeup I use this as my primer and I
know you're gonna say this is the wrong
color
I know teenager driving a car for the
first time I just run this sponge all
over my face and I blend it into my neck
because one of the things that I do
terribly is leave patches along my
jawline and onto my neck this has great
coverage if you like light coverage like
that more power to you I use it like I
said it's a primer so I'm gonna put if
I'm gonna do my real make up routine for
you this is what I really do you never
find the exact right color foundation so
I always end up mixing a bunch of shapes
because I put on fake Tanner and then it
washes off and so my the balance of my
skin tone is all over the place I mix
this Revlon Colorstay but this L'Oreal
infallible Pro glow because this is
shiny this is more matte and I feel like
maybe they meet in the middle put a
little bit of that on of addition and
then I smash them in my skin I know this
seems we're done
I know it just seems like I'm piling on
there's one thing I love it's piling on
okay now I go for under-eye aide rewind
eraser dark circles from Maybelline
again I smash it in my under eye but
like two hammocks under my eyes look at
that instantly well-rested look at that
powder cosplay next thing I do is my
eyebrows I use this incredibly
disgusting and has not been cleaned
makeup brush honest Asya beverly hills
dipbrow in a color that they sent to me
a long time ago for free and is probably
bacteria filled but I refuse to let it
go okay then we just fill in our
eyebrows oh do I look sly or like I am
judging you that then I do this I go
with the shape in here oh wow curtain
Ernie could never I don't wear a ton of
eye makeup when I'm doing like an
everyday makeup look so what I do do
focus on my mascara label has been
completely blocked off but basically
it's like an eyelash mascara primer when
it dries you can put mascara over it and
it makes your eyelashes look bigger
bolder braver uncut etc I like the sound
clip movie this is one of those fun
things that you put on your face at like
if you went to the grocery store like
this it's not enough for someone to say
like what's going on there but it's
enough for a stranger to just make a
mental note to themselves to go that
wasn't correct what I saw with that
person on their face let's move on to
bronzer urban decay beached bronzer in
sunkissed I'm hitting pan just
terminology for makeup gurus they're
like when you get to the bottom of a
product and hit the pan bash this into
the yeah like that there's a bronzer
look at that well who has been painting
walls and doors with no access to
sunlight not this girl's just clearly
been on these beaches of Barbados next I
get into my mascara I've been using a
mix of tarts man-eater tarts lights
camera lashes we just go nuts on this
my mascara application face is very much
like I forgot I ate in edible and now
I'm an hour into planet Earth - and it's
a lot fun cute now I put blush on a
Tarte fearless blush that I've had for
probably too long and maybe it's
collected bacteria but can't smell
bacteria was that bar fun okay so a
basic makeup routine when then usually I
spray it with all nighter from Urban
Decay again this could just be like
sugar water that I'm spraying into my
face but I paid too much for it and I
believe it works I usually don't put
like a lip thing on because I've
chapstick in my car that I put on if I
have to go someplace but just for the
purpose of doing a full get ready with
me this is sexy mother pucker from soap
& Glory
it's called fair enough yeah okay now
let's do our hair look at this yeah
looks great my hair's been doing cosplay
it's like a stainless steel kitchen
sponge so that's what my hair looks like
when I wash it and then I just let it
air dry overnight
it looks like that accidentally bought
this batiste dry shampoo that's
specifically for blonde hair we scrub
that in Wow who knew that the after
could be this great I have my hair
straightener here mayhaps I put this in
a montage because I don't want the
pressure having to talk through how long
this takes
I want to see my impression of Robert
DeNiro waking up for the first time with
like long luxurious locks I'm trying to
straighten it for the first time in his
life
[Applause]
there we go Wow look at that
who is she but never suspect that I am
true actual garbage trash human being
there you go there's my everyday get
ready with me routine from skincare to
makeup - hair I hope that you learned
something
no I hope you didn't learn anything this
is the prank I pull on the rest of
society to allow them to believe that I
have far more capable and put together
than I actually am thank you guys for
watching if you liked this video give it
a thumbs up and turn on those bail
notifications so you know when I post
videos because as you probably know by
now I post them don't forget to get your
tickets to this make it weird podcast
tour all the links in the description
box below listen to the podcast that
comes out every Wednesday not too deep
my other podcast thumbs up every Monday
another than that I don't know
everything